so what do we say about this
uh this image that i think is spread far
and wide now
of a navy veteran wearing a navy vet
garb
right um which he says he did
intentionally so that
uh in the hopes that he would get
interaction
uh you know decent human interaction
from the officers whom he was facing
uh whom we see standing tall and proud
and alone
and being beaten on by police until he
finally turns around and
reports later that he is um that he is
somewhat damaged as you would expect he
would be
yeah um we we know something you know
we have some thoughts about what's going
on you want to start
well i would just say that it raises a
question i mean it's
first of all a very dramatic piece of
footage that somebody quite dramatic
is standing there and withstanding a
physical attack that's
quite powerful but there's also a
question about you know
what was the interaction that resulted
in that attack
and um we've heard uh
we've heard that there had been regular
announcements
for you know many minutes up to an hour
beforehand
by and i don't know if it was the police
the federal officers to clear the area
to get out of the area
they were going to start using if it was
if they said tear gas it was federal
officers because local police aren't
allowed to
uh and that that that looks
true to me uh in part because the scene
is otherwise empty
uh in the scene that is these scenes
that we're seeing from that particular
part of
portland at those times of night for the
last consecutive whatever you said 54
days
is always chaotic with lots of people
running uh back and forth
and everywhere and so um this this looks
to have been a scene that had been
cleared and was
attempted to be being cleared and you
know that doesn't
that presumably doesn't justify a
beating
but it also doesn't make that that man
an innocent as he is betraying himself
and this i mean this
this is the thing is how much of what we
are hearing
is pr and how would we know like that
that's the question
always we certainly experienced this at
evergreen when we started to see the pr
machine
you know get tripped into gear and start
making actions that they knew would play
well with some part of the outside world
yeah so obviously a tall strong
independent man in navy
where patriot patriot who is being
beaten on
this looks like the authoritarian
madness that we are being told is rife
in every police department across the
country
uh but i don't think that's what we were
actually saying and you have to play it
through
so let's imagine that you decided to
precipitate an event and so the police
say
clear out we're about to uh to come
through the area
you approach them instead you have some
interaction where you refuse to go
now might be that what they should have
done is handcuffed him and dragged him
off i don't but i don't
we don't know the situation because what
we have is exactly what fell in the
frame
we don't have the context that happened
before we don't have the contents of the
interaction between him and the officers
and so the point is yeah that looks um
that looks bad
we have two we have two types of media
and
this that story that we've all now seen
at least pieces of plays really well
with cnn
and with npr and with msnbc and some
alternative story will play really well
with fox
and you know fox mostly um you know and
and a lot of minor outlets that don't
have as much play
uh but basically all of these outlets
fall prey to just reporting on the
narrative that they always already agree
with
all right that's that's what they do
[Music]